ABC AFTER LEAD ACTOR MADE
SOME REMARKS ON TWITTER THAT
SHE REGRETTED.
FOR NOW OUR EYES ARE ON THE
PRESIDENT WHO HAS ENJOYED
RISING APPROVAL RATINGS AND
INTERVENING MORE AND
EARIVELY BEFORE MIDTERM
ELECTIONS.
MID TERMS TYPICALLY GO BADLY
FOR THE INCUMBENT PARTY:  WE
ARE JOINT TONIGHT BY SENIOR
POLITICAL ANALYST BRIT HUME.
WOULD THESE HELP THE
CANDIDATE.
>> THE CANDIDATE WHO IS.
>> Tucker: FOR WHOM THE
PRESIDENT IS STUMPING.
>> I THINK IN THIS CASE.
THE STATE OF TENNESSEE IS A
STATE THAT THE PRESIDENT
CARRIED EASILY.
THERE IS A REASONABLY
POPULAR CANDIDATE ON THE
OTHER SIDE PHIL BRED SON WHO
WAS GOVERNOR AND HAS BEEN
WELL-REGARDED IN THE STATE.
HE IS AHEAD IN WHAT FEW
POLLS THERE ARE.
SO, BUT MARSHA BLACKBURN HAS
A REAL CHANCE TO TAKE THE
SEAT FOR THE REPUBLICANS AND
SHE WILL NEED THE SUPPORT OF
THE TRUMP.
SHE WILL CERTAINLY NEED THAT
AND HIS BEING THERE HELPS
WITH THAT OTHER THING ABOUT
IT OF COURSE IS HE LOVES
THIS.
>> Tucker: HE DOES LOVE IT.
NO DOUBT ABOUT THAT.
>> IN WASHINGTON HE FEELS
COOPSD UP AND CRITICIZED AND
KIND OF LIKE A MAN ON AN
ISLAND AND HE GETS OUT TO
THESE RALLIES WHERE HE PACKS
THESE HUGE HOUSES AND ALL
FULLY ADVANCED BY HIS TEAM
AND PEOPLE COME AND CHEER
WILDLY FOR HIM AND IT MAKES
HIM FEEL GOOD BILL CLINTON
WAS THE SAME WAY.
HE GOT ENERGY FROM IT.
PEOPLE WHO COVERED HIM ON
HIS CAMPAIGN, WHICH I
COVERED HIM AS PRESIDENT BUT
NOT ON THE CAMPAIGN WOULD
SAY AT THE END OF THE DAY,
EVERYONE WOULD BE EXHAUSTED
AND HE SEEMED TO BE SOME
RALLY AND PEOPLE CHEERING
LIKE MAD AND HE WAS FULL CRY
AND ROARING WITH ENERGY AND
COULDN’T GET ENOUGH OF IT
TRUMP SEEMS MUCH THE SAME
WAY.
>> Tucker: THE DEBATE OVER
WHOSE PARTY IS THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY IT’S
TRUMP’S PARTY.
>> IT IS.
BUT CONSIDER -- I THINK IT’S
ALSO FAIR TO SAY, TUCKER,
FOR ALL THE TALK ABOUT HOW
THE PARTY HAS BEEN
COMPLETELY TAKEN OVER BY
TRUMP AND THE -- AND IT WILL
NOT -- IT WILL BE HIS PARTY
IN PERPETUITY, I THINK THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY AND ITS
INFLUENCE ON HIM THAN HE HAS
HAD ON THEM.
>> Tucker: WHY DO YOU SAY
THAT?
>> BECAUSE YOU LOOK AT THE
ISSUES, RIGHT?
TAXES.
HE TALKED ABOUT THAT.
THAT’S A CENTRAL REPUBLICAN
TENET.
STRONGER DEFENSE, ALSO,
LIKEWISE A CENTRAL REPUCK
REPUBLICAN TENET.
DEREGULATION, THAT’S A BEEN
A REPUBLICAN RED LETTER
ISSUE FOREVER.
ONLY ISSUES WHICH HE HAS
DEPARTED ARE IMMIGRATION AND
TRADE.
IT’S NOT AT ALL CLEAR WHEN
ALL IS SAID AND DONE WHETHER
WHAT COMES OUT OF ALL OF
THIS THE POLICIES THAT
EMERGE ARE OBJECTIONABLE TO
THE REPUBLICAN MAINSTREAM.
>> Tucker: IF THERE WERE A
THIRD PARTY CHALLENGE.
WHAT WOULD THE THIRD PARTY
CHALLENGER RUN ON EXACTLY.
>> WELL A THIRD PARTY
CHALLENGE TO TRUMP OR A
CANDIDATE?
>> Tucker: CANDIDATE.
>> IT WOULD HAVE TO BE ON
THE ISSUE OF PERSONAL
CHARACTER.
PEOPLE WOULD SAY, YOU KNOW,
WHICH IS THE ISSUE THAT GOT
GEORGE W. BUSH ELECTED BUT
NOT NECESSARILY WITHIN THE
REPUBLICAN RANKS.
WHITE HOUSE, OF COURSE IN
THE AFTERMATH OF THE CLINTON
SCANDALS THAT CARRIED WEIGHT
AND DAMAGING TO AL GORE WHO
HAD TO FIGHT -- HE HAD TO
MAKE THE DECISION HOW
CLOSELY TO LINK HIMSELF TO
CLINTON AND THE ROBUST
ECONOMY AND WAS ARGUED
FOREVER THAT HE DIDN’T DO
THAT ENOUGH OR HE DID IT TOO
MUCH.
THAT WAS A BURDEN ON HIM FOR
SURE.
AND BUSH CAPITALIZED ON IT.
WHETHER THAT WILL WORK IN A
REPUBLICAN PRIMARY AT THIS
STAGE I DON’T THINK SO.
I THINK TRUMP HAS TAKEN OVER
MOST OF THE REPUBLICAN
AGENDA.
>> Tucker: SO ON THE ISSUES,
YOU DON’T SEE ANY KIND OF
CHALLENGE FOR THE
NOMINATION?
>> WELL, PEOPLE.
I DON’T THINK ANYONE CAN
CHALLENGE HIM FROM THE LEFT
ON IMMIGRATION OR
PARTICULARLY ON TRADE.
ALTHOUGH ONE OF THE PROBLEMS
WITH TRUMP’S TRADE AGENDA IS
THAT IT COULD GO WRONG.
AND WE COULD END UP, YOU
KNOW, WITH TRADE BARRIERS
UP.
WE HAVE SORT OF BACKED INTO
OR, YOU KNOW, SORT OF
AND THE ECONOMY COULD GET
HURT BY THAT.
AND, YOU KNOW, YOU COULD
HAVE SOMEBODY RUNNING
AGAINST HIM ON THE ECONOMY.
BUT THE ECONOMY WOULD HAVE
TO GO PRETTY FAR SOUTH FROM
WHERE IT IS NOW FOR THAT TO
HAPPEN.
>> HOW BOOYED DO YOU THINK
TRUMP IS REPUBLICANS ARE BY
THE POTENTIAL NORTH KOREAN
DEAL?
>> WELL, I THINK TRUMP WAS
PRETTY EXCITED ABOUT IT,
ABOUT THE POTENTIAL OF IT I
WILL SAY THIS.
MY CONCERN HAS BEEN AND IS
NOW THAT HE GETS INTO THE
SUMMIT AND THE POSSIBILITY
OF A DEAL THAT WOULD
DENUCLEARIZE IT AND END THE
KOREAN WAR AND THE REST OF
IT THAT HE MAKES A BAD DEAL.
THAT HE GETS EUCHRED WHICH
IS WHAT HAS HAPPENED BEFORE
REPEATEDLY.
SO FAR THOUGH, IT SEEMS TO
ME THAT DESPITE HIS EXCITED
TALK AND HIS BUYING IN AT
LEAST A LITTLE BIT TO THE
NOBEL PRIZE TALK, HIS
WILLINGNESS TO SAY OKAY,
THIS IS OFF SUGGESTS TO ME
THAT, YOU KNOW, HE HAS HIS
EYES WIDE OPEN AND THE
PEOPLE AROUND HIM DO, TOO.
IF HE GETS OVER THERE OR IF
THEY TRY TO ORGANIZE THIS
THING AND IT’S COMING TO PUT
THAT, THAT HE IS WILLING TO
WALK AWAY.
BUT IF HE DIDN’T DO THAT.
AND HE GOT INTO A BAD DEAL,
THAT MIGHT LEAVE
VULNERABILITY.
>> YOU POINTING IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION FOR REPUBLICANS,
FOR THE WHITE HOUSE.
>> THEY CERTAINLY LOOK A LOT
BETTER THAN THEY DID SIX
MONTHS AGO.
>> Tucker: MUCH BETTER.
WHAT WOULD HAPPEN IF
DEMOCRATS FAILED TO RETAKE
THE HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES?
WHAT WOULD THE RECKONING BE
LIKE DO YOU THINK WITHIN THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY?
>> IT WOULD BE PRETTY
SERIOUS.
I THINK THE MESSAGE THAT
WOULD PROBABLY COME OUT OF
THAT WOULD BE THAT BEING,
YOU KNOW, JUST
OVERWHELMINGLY ANTI-TRUMP IS
NOT ENOUGH.
THAT WHILE THAT AWAKENS THE
SENTIMENTS IN THE BASE AND
RESPONSIBLE FOR A LOT OF THE
ENERGY IN THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY THESE DAYS, THAT THAT
IN ITSELF IS NOT ENOUGH.
IT’S TOO NEGATIVE.
DOESN’T PAINT A PICTURE OF
HOW MUCH BETTER THINGS COULD
BE.
IT DOESN’T REALLY AROUSE
PEOPLE -- MOST PEOPLE ARE
NOT PASSIONATE ONE WAY OR
THE OTHER.
MOST PEOPLE WILLING TO VOTE
ON A MIDTERM WANT TO HEAR
FROM SOMEBODY WHO SAYS,
LOOK, I CAN MAKE THINGS
BETTER FOR YOU AND HERE IS
HOW.
AND IF YOU HAVEN’T GOT THAT
IN A WAY THAT AND IF YOU RUN
AS A DEMOCRAT, SOME
DEMOCRATS SEEM PREPARED TO
DO IT.
VOTE FOR ME, I WILL RAISE
YOUR TAXES.
THAT’S PROBABLY NOT GOING TO
WORK EITHER.
>> Tucker: DO YOU SEE ANY
STIRRINGS IN THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY WHICH IS REALIGNS AGO
I THINK THE REPUBLICAN PARTY
IS THOUGH IT GETS LITTLE
COVERAGE.
ANY STIRRINGS OF A POSITIVE
AGENDA.
WE ARE AGAINST TRUMP OF
COURSE WE ARE BUT HERE IS
WHAT WE ARE FOVMENT DO YOU
SEE ANYTHING ALONG THOSE
LINES.
>> GROW.
I’M NOT SURE HOW WE WOULD
KNOW.
THE TRUTH IS WHEN YOU GET
DOWN TO IT, TUCKER, THERE
ARE NOT A LOT OF NEW IDEAS.
YOU ARE USUALLY FOR REIGNING
IN GOVERNMENT.
CONTROLLING SPENDING
ALTHOUGH REPUBLICANS HAVE
KIND OF GIVEN UP ON THAT.
AND AT LEAST IN RECENT
TIMES.
LOWER TAXES.
STERNER DEFENSE.
TOUGHER FOREIGN POLICY.
ALL OF THAT RIGHT?
SOFT REGULATION.
DEMOCRATS ARE FOR THE
OPPOSITE THINGS.
AND THEY ALWAYS WILL BE.
THAT’S WHAT THEY ARE ABOUT.
YOU KNOW, SO YOU CAN RUN ON
A PLATFORM THAT SAYS LOOK,
YOU KNOW, TRUMP IS
DESTROYING THE ENVIRONMENT.
IS HE LETTING THE CORPORATE
MOGULS RUN AMUCK AND BIG
BANKS ARE CASHING IN AS
NEVER BEFORE.
WE HAVE GOT TO PUT A STOP TO
THIS.
THAT WILL ATTRACT SOME
SUPPORT.
THAT SEEMS PRETTY TIRED
RIGHT NOW.